la fin d'un mystère tout de suite sous
mesure que se cache-t-il derrière ce
tableau réponse à un truc pour jouer au
morpion réponse mais un portrait robot
de squeeze réponse et zz réponse des
chip rien et maintenant fin des votes
est sous vos yeux
voilà ils pourront pas percé le mystère
avant je le perçois même les amis avez
vous vu la vidéo récente de celle qui
s'appelle vous et moi dans laquelle il
parle de sa relation avec ses abonnés
comment tout ce délire virtuel se
retranscrit dans la vraie vie à travers
devrait rencontrer des vrais moments
parfois coule parfois gênant parfois
étranges aller voir ces vidéos si vous
l'avez pas fait parce qu'elle est
vraiment marrant et je me suis reconnu
dans 100 % de ce qu'il a dit ça va
donner une idée et je me suis rappelé de
pas mal de rencontres que j'ai fait avec
des abonnés dans la vraie vie avec vous
mais du coup des rencontres pas du tout
organisé pas détruits dans des
conventions pas des trucs où je sais que
je vais faire des rencontres que tu sois
avec des proches où seuls prêts s'est
pas pressé dans 98% des cas quand les
gens viennent de voir ces bienveillance
et respectueux c'est mignon vraiment
c'est trop mignon et moi j'ai essayé de
renvoyer du gentil en face mais je vous
connais pas donc je galère à trouver les
mots away et toi tu vas tu va être une
super maman plus tard je pense je ne
sais pas quoi dire comme compliment mais
les gens ont envie d'en dire puisque
vous complimenter vous avez l'air tout
gentil mais je sais rien de vous alors
c'est très compliqué aujourd'hui je vais
pas vous parler de toutes ces rencontres
positives agréable cool et qui
représente vraiment la majorité des fois
je vous vois je vais vous parler d'une
minorité de rencontres qui m'ont
traumatisé ça veut pas forcément dire
que la personne en face était
respectueuse ou quoi on pas du tout mais
le contexte où la manière de faire la
personne pour certains faits que j'ai eu
un réel traumatisme est vraiment réel
traumatisme première situation il est
vrai un jour dans ma vie j'ai eu une
douleur pendant plusieurs jours à ce
qu'on appelle une énorme couilles sakho
ainsi bien et ayant beaucoup trop
traîner sur internet et surtout les gens
qui s'autoproclament médecin et qui te
disent ce qu'ils pensent que tu as alors
qu'il tombe pas du tout examiné ce
qu'ils savent de ce que tu as et ton
auto examen at war transcrit à l'écrit
d'une manière dégueulasse et la personne
en face l'iton auto-examen dégueulasse
et fait un diagnostic si vous avez un
problème vous avez mal quelque part vous
sentez pas bien blabla aller chez un
médecin ne voudrais pas internet c'est
le début d'une grosse tourmente
autrement dont moi à l'époque je savais
pas ça donc qu'est-ce que je fais jouer
internet en ne disant pas à tous les
coups je veux dire que c'est un petit
truc une petite torsion d'un canola des
couilles qui va se remettre droit et on
en parle plus du tout qu'est ce que je
lis
je me suis un très bien tac couilles va
atteindre 5 fois sa taille normale et
devenir rouge situe n'agit pas dans les
deux heures tu peut la perdre
je vais faire d'une cui moi donc je
prends au sérieux tout ça je commence à
me mettre dans des états pas possibles
etc vous en faites pas la personne
abonnée arrive ça arrive alors vous
dites y'a pas de rapport mais un rapport
et il est immense du coup j'appelle une
clinique qui fait des échographies et
leur demande s'ils font des échographies
testiculaire c'est le nom scientifique
de l'échographie des couilles la
personne me répond que oui totalement
c'est un truc qui se fait dans cette
lignée que je peux venir le lendemain à
13 h
bon bah cool j'espère juste que ma coup
il ne va pas mourir dans la nuit le
lendemain je vais là-bas je suis dans
une salle d'attenté où se trouvent
d'autres hommes que je regarde en me
disant est ce qu'ils vont aussi se faire
une échographie qui destitue le ou pas
parce qu'ils ont l'air dans un meilleur
round que moi désolé c'était la première
fois que je devais montrer mes parties à
un médecin pour des raisons médicales ya
aucune honte à ça en vrai le médecin il
s'en fout mais un point mais colossal
quoi et moi c'était ma première fois un
mois comme le scanner une partie intime
donc j'étais pas bien quoi le médecin
vient je lui serre la main je surveille
son visage pour être sûr que le mec qui
va me scanner la couille
c'est pas un abonné parce que c'est trop
chelou quoi c'est trop bizarre si c'est
un abonné jory regarde mes vidéos et
tout il aime bien machin et là ils ont
même touché une couille fins et
psychologiquement c'est bizarre quoi je
me sens pas bien vu son âge et comment
il m'a regardé et c'est je me dis que
non c'est bon c'est pas un abonné tout
va bien donc j'arrive dans cette salle
sombre
il me dit de me mettre des testicules a
l'air finalement un ce que je fais et
puis il prend sa sonde lime et du gel au
bout et hop il la pose délicatement sur
ma testicules et il fait son écot ça
dure un peu fini et il me dit bon bah
vous n'avez pas grand chose
vous avez même rien en fait vous devez
avoir une petite torsion dans la nuit
vous avez du mal vous m ca de vous faire
mal mais il ya vraiment rien quoi moi je
vois rien vous en faites pas tout va
bien là je me sens héroïque je me dis
[ __ ] j'ai traversé cette épreuve
en plus je n'ai rien mac où il va bien
je vais la garder je suis heureux et
pendant que je suis dans mes pensées
le médecin me dit sinon j'aime bien vos
vidéos en continu et attendait est ce
qu'un abonné vient de me scanner la
couille
maintenant il y en a qui peuvent croire
que m'a manqué de respect mais en vrai
il a vu que j'étais en panique pendant
tout le truc extra donc il m'a rien dit
de a à z et à l'arrivée c'était plus
fort que lui voulait me dire j'aime bien
ce que tu fais continuer c'était pas
méchant de sa part c'était bien sûr mais
moi ça va trop bas il ya quand même une
personne parmi vous qui m'a touché la
cuy voit la foule tir et c'était pas un
délire
tu perds ou qua non non c'était juste
une échographie de la queen mum salami
mec je suis rentré comme ça et j'ai
regardé comme ça par la fenêtre pendant
deux heures en me disant [ __ ] de merde
si je pensais un jour que ça
m'arriverait dans ma vie bon deuxième
rencontre un peu chelou j'étais en train
de balader natsu un matin j'étais mal
luné d'ouf mais des fois je me levais le
matin je suis mal luné comme tous les
humains et je me dirige vers une marque
qui vend des cafés à emporter
article 13 on sait jamais et là
j'entends quoi un mec m'a crié dessus si
fort que je pense qu'ils étaient à 1 km
de moi ils étaient 1 km et quand c'est
comme ça en fait ça fait un peu peur de
l'effet son bide lors que tous les gens
tourne la tête vers man etc
et j'aime pas du tout me faire remarquer
dans la rue pas du tout parce que je
suis une personnalité du net ou qua non
juste parce que je veux pas me faire
voir je suis tranquille quoi album c'est
comme quand tu es dans un monde où
taylor d'une espèce de solitude des fois
pendant quelques heures et tu deviens
une sorte d'animal cours si on touche tu
fais des aides tu peux mort de quoi
calmes bon bah je vais marcher et faire
genre je n'ai pas entendu il ya un
kilomètre veille il va comprendre que
j'ai même entendu deuxième crise quoi ce
jeu me met à marcher un peu
là on y va mais ils étaient déterminés
qu'est ce que j'entends pendant que je
fais cette marche athlétique
le mec a fait à 150 mètres sprint et là
le gars arrive à ma hauteur et je me dis
moi ça y est maintenant qu'ils matin et
va être cool et est posée et va
peut-être même s'excuser d'avoir gueuler
grave des fois pas du tout il me frappe
les poules il me frappe les poules une
tata de mon gars même mon père et mon
apam il est comme ça alors tu m'entends
pas tu m'entends pas quand je crie la
route c'est emma pur laitue même ma mère
quand je faisais du pc en cachette le
mur les pas dessus comme ça tu n'es pas
maintenant tu cries plus fort qu'elle et
c'était pas du tout rendu compte
à aucun moment que c'est assez brusque
ans pour un être humain que quelques
arthur le dessus à multiples reprises et
que quand ils arrivent à ton niveau il
te frappe l'épaule et il m'a demandé une
photo pour son fils mme chez put rocky
et ça m'a rendu ou feront plus autant ne
pas poser la question du est ce que je
suis en train de l'importuner ou pas tu
as et du coup je vais expliquer
gentiment je lui ai dit mais je suis
vraiment désolé mais là juste tu viens
durée les pleins de foi squeeze dans la
rue ça m'a ultra gêné et quand arrive
c'est pas gentil tum tum aborde
gentiment si tu mets un coup dans les
pôles tu vois pas cool donc non je fais
pas ta photo et la prochaine fois
repenser à ton comportement quoi je suis
un humain tu peux pas me prendre pour un
animal tu vois et le gars il a vrillé et
il s'est mis à m'insulter m'a regardé en
mode away espèce d'enfoiré va connard et
c'est ça qui m'a trop mal quoi c'est que
le gars il avoue
et d'un coup et m'a insulté genre il est
un scandale quoi devant tout le monde
alors juste je venais de me faire crier
dessus alors je n'avais rien demandé je
promenais mon chien tranquillement s'il
avait fait une démarche respectueuse et
bienveillant tueur ait eu aucun souci
mais la mixité s'est agacé j'entends
encore ces jeux je vous jure que dans
quelqu'un vous crie dessus comme ça en
public aussi forte qui vous courent
après et qui a tous les gens qui vous
regardent pas ce qu'ils comprennent pas
ce qui se passe bah t'as pas envie de
donner à la personne ce qu'elle voulait
parce que c'est lui donner raison
d'avoir eu un tel comportement je trouve
il ya plein de fois où j'ai laissé
passer d'eux ouvre des trucs comme ça et
cette fois là je me suis dit non là
c'est trop c'est n'importe quoi c'est je
peins d'animal quoi c'est n'importe quoi
c'était vraiment chaud gros fake je me
suis créé dessus insulté par un inconnu
dans la rue j'ai passé une bonne journée
et j'en viens donc à la 3ème anecdote un
jour j'étais au japon en vacances
tranquillement et je me baladais dans un
quartier à tokyo j'ai vu qu'il y avait
des un petit groupe de français qui
m'avait reconnu mais jamais le
comportement de ceux qui tous reconnus
qui osent pas venir te taper sur
l'épaule pour tu te retournes et qui du
coup rester une certaine distance et te
suivre pendant plus ou moins longtemps
en faisant se croiser de temps en temps
mais ils l'ont fait pendant super
longtemps au genre pendant 25 minutes du
haj marché et ça faisait squeeze et
comme j'étais au japon en mode vacances
gros break avec youtube etc internet et
tout ça me ramener à mon quotidien et ça
me rendait un pouf quoi j'étais en mode
non laissez moi j'étais un ogre un ogre
est en fait je prends une rue à gauche
pour aller dans une boutique et le mec
se détache de son groupe prend la rue
une suite et puis une tape sur l'épaule
et je me retourne et je m'en veux encore
mais vous allez voir la suite ça finit
bien jouer tellement mal parlé j'ai
vraiment été un gros con et je m'en suis
voulu mec déjà tu cries mon nom depuis
juste pas combien de temps c'est bon je
t'ai entendu et ensuite lâché en
vacances je fais pas de photo je suis un
air désolé bonne journée et en me
retournant pendant je lui ai dit ce
discours de connard j'ai vu son visage
aux gars un visage mignon heureux
vraiment de deux gars gentil qui voulait
vraiment pas déranger mais cas pas pu
s'empêcher de venir me voir s qui sait
que ça se reproduira pas et qui voulait
me dire quelque chose et je sais pas
pendant cinq minutes j'y pense et comme
ça dans le magasin et je me dise pas
possible faut que j'y retourne c'est
trop injuste ce que ce que je lui ai mis
dans la tête c'est parfaitement juste il
faut que j'aille le voir pour m'excuser
et donc je pars en courant du magasin je
cours comme ça dans la rue je cherche du
regard à gauche à droite je le vois pas
et je cours je cours je cours et au
final je finis par l'apercevoir il avait
rejoint son groupe de potes et je lui
dis re
suis vraiment désolé de ce que je t'ai
dit et tout c'était vraiment pas sympa
de m'a pas vraiment je m'excuse et tout
est le mec me regarde et me dit ah mais
y'a pas de souci était en vacances je
comprends il ya aucun problème
t'inquiète je suis vraiment désolé de
t'avoir déranger et là j'avais envie de
pleurer tellement il était gentil quoi
gentil et trop bienveillant le mec
j'avais très mal parlé et il a tellement
pas mal pris il était tellement en mode
wes pas grave il est occupé il est en
vacances avec sa maman je comprends et
tellement gentil et j'étais tellement
content d'être retourné le voit qu'on a
parlé pendant 15 minutes avec lui et ses
potes et c'était un expatrié et ses
potes avaient rejoint ou au japon et du
coup il se faisait une petite semaine
entre potes là-bas et c'était vraiment
cool comme moment comme discussions et
tout donc merci à tous je regarde cette
vidéo et ça montre que des fois les gens
qui quittent à cause peuvent mal s'y
prendre mais nous aussi dans notre
réponse des fois on peut encore plus mal
s'y prendre voilà ça va marquer tu es à
deux ans et j'y pense encore
régulièrement et à chaque fois je pense
à ça et je me dis peu importe la
personne qui vient te voir c'est pas
méchant tu vois sont juste toucher de
doigt en vrai même si ça te dérange
parfois parce que tu es pressé ou thé
dans un vieux mood etc il faut pas les
traiter comme ce jour là j'ai traité ce
gars là ça a été une vraie leçon pour
moi donc merci a toi bon une fois il
m'est arrivé quelque chose d'horrible ya
quatre ans mon adresse avait fuité sur
internet voilà c'est la pire chose qui
peut arriver tout simplement pour un
youtuber c'est horrible parce que ya pas
mal de gens parmi vous qui ont du mal à
concevoir ça mais a vraiment des gens
qui viennent qui sonne qui ressort qui
ressort qui finalement harcèle en fait
ici je suis au studio je suis au bureau
chez dans le cadre professionnel donc je
m'en fous un peu mais dans la vie privée
c'est choquant à des groupes de gens qui
sonne chez toi en boucle etc
c'est pas amusant et en fait ça m'était
arrivé à arcueil cachan à l'époque
j'habitais mon adresse avait pas fuité
sur le net mais il y avait une
université où les gens savaient que
j'habitais là mais c'était quand même un
immeuble avec digicode etc
il sonne à l'interphone bon ça allait
mais après j'ai déménagé je suis allé
dans une maison à la lru et une maison
il n'y avait pas de portail et avait
accès à la porte d'entrée de la maison
comme ça c'était côté rue ils n'avaient
pas portail n'est un pas de protection
et en fait quand je rentrais tous les
jours il y avait des jeunes devant la
maison donc je leur disais bon les amis
c'est la vie privée la vous attendez
devant chez moi et tout c'est un peu
limite quoi mais le pire c'est que des
fra j'étais dans le salon je regardais
du netflix ou je sais pas quoi et avec
les fenêtres à droite comme ça et je
regardais à droite et je voyais des gens
qui avaient leur visage collé comme ça
qu'ils regardaient chez moi comme ça
j'ai regardé et je pouvais rien faire
j'étais en mode
c'est ça ma vie c'est avoir des petits
lutins comme ça au fne qui font et je
sais que c'est trop pas méchant de la
part de ces personnels ça pas du tout
que ça te fait du mal et que ça te met 7
mais cette fois elles savent pas du tout
elle doute pas souvent c'est des gens à
ces jeunes qui font ça c'est pas du tout
des gens comme mon âge ou quoi c'est des
gens ou moi aussi à leur âge avaient pas
conscience commence à ge sa importune la
personne que tu regardes en fait et donc
ça a été ça pendant pendant de nombreux
mois un niqab à tous ces gens qui m'ont
vu en slip sur mon canapé qui sont venus
voir ma fenêtre
j'espère au moins que vous vous passiez
un boom j'espère le spectacle était à la
hauteur de vos attentes
et dernière chose une rencontre y'a pas
longtemps que j'ai fait il ya aussi des
gens qui sont ultra mignons ils viennent
et ils veulent absolument pas te
déranger même si tu leur dis non mais tu
me dérange pas ils vont me dire si je te
dérange je vois bien revoir un catch
thème arbres et c'est trop mignon de
leur part est en fait il t'aime
tellement qu'ils veulent pas prendre le
millet risque de d'importuner le sait
les frais chié tout s'est tellement
tellement adorable et ce matin encore
dans mon chien de cette vidéo un gars
que je vais appeler monsieur superdry
parce qu'il avait un sac à dos
superdrive tout ce dont je me souviens
kruger batwa physicien cette vidéo est
il venu et il me dit j'ai pas
d'importuner mais merci pour tes vidéos
elles m'ont aidé dans un moment ma vie
où j'étais pas très bien elles m'ont
vraiment fait du bien depuis j'ai
remonté la pente mais voilà je voulais
te remercier pour ce que tu as fait pour
moi et bonne coordination et il se barre
comme ça et moi j'avais envie de lui
parler monsieur superdry attendez vous
êtes tellement sympathique et lui
partait quoi qu'il arrive comme s'il
était mort et que son âme était resté
sur terre et qu'il avait besoin de me
dire ça avant de s'envoler au paradis tu
sais vraiment pas ce que j'ai ressenti
j'aurais pu crier parce que je voulais
dans une partie il a dit ce qu'il avait
à dire il part la tête haute et heureux
de ce moment très court mais très
intense de voilà n'hésitez pas à faire
un gros big up à monsieur pas vrai dans
les commentaires ça lui fera plaisir
il était adorable c'est la fin de ces
péripéties qui sortait du commun il ya
eu plein de rangoon n'y avait pas des
trucs comme ça faisait beaucoup plus
tranquille normale est cool mais là
c'est vraiment celle qui m'ont marqué en
tout cas si vous croisez un youtuber ou
un chanteur ou un acteur je sais pas que
vous adorez vous voulez aller le voir
fait toujours dans une démarche
respectueuse c'est à dire s'il est en
famille ou entre amis vous savez que
c'est un moment où il est en train qui
fait avec des gens avec du coup vous
couper ce moment là si vous allez le
voir crier pas sont allés le voir
tranquillement indiscrets up et je vous
jure que là il ya aucun problème et
parfois même moi quand je disais quand
je suis à la boulangerie ou en train de
sortir un truc tout ça me dérange pas de
vous parler pendant un petit moment mais
parfois quand je suis pas disponible
entre guillemets bah je vais je vais
écourté le truc je vais être moi dedans
quoi mais faut pas en vouloir c'est
qu' il ya des moments pour des moments
qui sont moins tour et dans tous les cas
c'est cool mais parfois ça peut être
plus court que d'autres moments voyage
pas si je suis très clair à bientôt tout
le monde au revoir et mai mais c'est
simplement sms et youtube avant eux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tout
m